the iPhone 15s are finally here and we
had a ton of leaks that were accurate
but with that there are 15 leaks that we
were super excited for that did not make
it to these phones some little ones and
some some really big disappointing ones
so let's go ahead and cover those number
one are the price increases we had a
bunch of leaks saying that these new
titanium phones will cost between 100
and 200 more but surprisingly the iPhone
15 Pro still costs the same 999 dollars
with the same amount of storage and
although the pro Max does cost 100 more
at its base price you get 256 gigs of
storage so the price tag is technically
the same especially for those that
bought the 256 gig models like I did now
in some countries the 15 Pros are
actually significantly cheaper than the
14 Pros thanks to the exchange rate
which people are rejoicing about number
two is Thunderbolt we were excited for
the fastest connection ever being put
into an iPhone coming from the slowest
one but we have USB type c with 10
gigabit per second speeds not even the
fastest USB so that means that even
though it is 20 times faster than the
iPhone 15 and the previous iPhones it is
still four times slower than Thunderbolt
now we had a bunch of rumors about this
so were they just wrong well no I don't
think so many times we get rumors more
than a year in advance so people think
that it's for the upcoming iPhone just
like they did when the Apple watch Ultra
was leaked years in advance Apple has to
build a thunderbolt controller into the
chip so I'm guessing that Thunderbolt
will likely come with the iPhone 16
Ultra now number three is USB type-c
limitation we had leaks that you would
have to buy a special mfi certified
expensive cable from Apple to get faster
USB transfer speeds but thankfully that
doesn't look like it's the case you can
use any USB type-cable table and it will
work and with that number four has got
to do with fast charging we had leaks
that we're gonna get 35 watt fast
charging coming from 20 watt that Apple
advertises but no that did not come out
so the speeds seem to be the same Apple
has not changed that and that means the
iPhones are still really behind their
Android competitors now number five with
that is we did not get those sweet
looking color matched braided cables we
just have one USB type-c cable that is
included it is braided but it is just a
standard white and that included cable
only has USB type 2 data transfer speeds
extremely slow so you'll probably have
to upgrade it if you use it next I want
to show you guys some new products from
our long-term partner moft they have
their new movas vegan leather that is
eco-friendly but very durable and high
quality at the same time now this is
moff's first leather case and it's
actually thinner and lighter than their
previous design the movas feels really
nice it doesn't leave any fingerprints
and it's really durable and then on the
inside we have this really soft suede
like material and then the buttons are
super nice here they are very tactile
and they have their movas updated snap
wallet which I have loved and used for
many years it's held up pretty dang good
but this one is actually more durable
the magnets are stronger and it can hold
your wallets but it can actually become
a stand which I use all the time both
vertically and horizontally they also
updated their snap battery pack with
that same movas and it has a nice strong
connection and we have the brand new
invisible tripod this thing is
incredibly unique you just snap it on
and then you can grab it and it
instantly extends like this to have a
floating tripod which you can use for
all sorts of scenarios and you can
literally adjust it however you want so
it's going to be incredibly useful so go
ahead and check out the links below to
all of moff's products including the
brand new movas products for your new
iPhone number six has also got to do
with charging but it's with magsafe
charging we had leaks of 20 watts coming
from 15 so it'd be a 25 charging speed
increase but that did not happen we
still have 15 watts and who knows maybe
that's going to come next year and that
leak was just ahead of its time number
seven has got to do with G2 Apple opened
up its magsafe design to the Qi wireless
charging standard so that Android phones
and other accessories can also use it
and we thought we're gonna get 15 watt
Max save charging through third-party
instead of being limited 7.5 but it
seems that even though these phones can
attach to G2 magnetic attachments you
are still going to get 7.5 wireless
charging which is half the speed and
that definitely is a bummer number eight
might be the most disappointing of all
we had leaks that the iPhone 15s are
gonna have a major battery life boost we
saw bigger capacities as far as the
battery size and we have the a17 chip
which is supposed to be way more
efficient on that three nanometer design
leading to some huge battery boosts
unfortunately the specs that Apple gave
out are identical to the iPhone 14s last
year now almost every year battery life
gets better and sometimes significantly
so but this year even with the a17 and
no new features that use extra battery
like the brighter display and the
dynamic Island they've got last year the
battery life stayed the same when it
should have gotten better and that is
worrisome with number nine we are
getting into cameras we had a recent
full spec sheet of the cameras and the
sensors and we saw that we're going to
get a 13.4 megapixel ultrawide sensor
and that the telephoto is going to be
12.7 meaning that we have brand new
updated sensors but no the iPhone 15
pros and the max they have the same
ultrawide as last year and the 15 Pro it
has the same exact 3x lens that we have
had for three years now so that did not
change and going into number 10 this is
for the pro Max we did not get that
rumored variable three to six the
optical zoom camera now this is a major
downside because that would have been
amazing and I have used a Sony
smartphone that had a variable zoom and
it was so nice because no matter how you
zoom the quality stayed the same now on
the pro max if you're going to zoom to
anything less than 5x it's actually
going to be a crop of that main sensor
just like it is on the regular 15 iPhone
and that means that with the 15 Pro if
you're going to take a picture between
3x and 5x the quality should actually be
better than the pro Max where you only
get to that new lens at 5x to take this
further Apple didn't show off any
portrait mode shots taken with the new
5x lens so there's a chance that you
might not be able to do so for portraits
and it will just be using the main lens
cropped now if you can it will still be
hard to do because 120 millimeters is
very far away even with a 3X I often had
to move backwards to take a picture and
when I was doing wedding photography I
actually bought a lens that was very
expensive in this Zoom range and I ended
up selling it because I was so far away
I had to yell at the couples that I was
taking pictures of so with that there's
a chance that I might actually go with
the regular 15 pro this year depending
how our real world tests show up so make
sure you guys are subscribed and number
11 is the a17 performance now the a16
was 10 10 percent more efficient than
the a15 while having 20 more CPU power
and 30 percent more GPU power with the
new a17 Pro you get a 10 CPU boost and a
20 GPU gain but that graphics
performance boost is actually from the
extra core which Stacks up to the
performance gain now this means that the
upcoming Snapdragon 8 gen 3 coming out
next month will beat out the a17 pro in
terms of Graphics now how is this
possible we had leaks of the a17 pro
showing that it's going to be running at
3.7 gigahertz compared to 3.46 on the
a16 and because of that the performance
is going to have a nice boost up to 7628
estimated for geekbench and then the
same thing for geekbench Metal Graphics
when we were seeing a 32 increase 29
425. those are the kind of gains that we
used to get year after year huge
improvements but this year this is the
smallest performance gain in many many
years so what is going on well we found
out that the a17 pro is using the n3b
process the first three nanometer
process from tsmc and this process is
really difficult to make but next year
they're going to switch over to n3e
which is going to have much better yield
it's going to be more mainstream it's
going to be cheaper and they actually
have to make some redesigns going up to
future generation chips now that chip is
actually not as good performance and
um that kind of doesn't make sense
because this one doesn't seem like it is
either but from what we're seeing Apple
is very likely down clocking this chip
limiting the performance so that next
year the gains can still keep passing on
in that next year they seem better so of
course we will see what the clock speeds
are once we get it and we will test it
out but that would suck if the
performance was supposed to be really
good but they're just capping it
artificially as for number 12 we did not
get the two terabyte storage option for
the pros now personally that's not
something that I would buy but since the
pro Max was starting at 256 gig and the
chips are available we thought Apple
would offer that but they are not now
thankfully it does seem like we are
getting the eight gigs of RAM so that is
a benefit but if you need in the same
amount of space well that is not there
number 13 is the physical SIM card slot
was set to be removed from a lot of
countries France was the last one that
people were talking about but no all the
other countries that had physical Sim
slots are still keeping them so that is
a positive and number 14 has got to do
with the colors we had that leaked
beautiful red titanium color and no that
did not come out of course we missed out
on the gold which I personally really
like and all the colors are very you did
now and very similar so I think that's a
bummer and a lot of people are
disappointed now with that the regular
iPhone 15 colors that were shown off
those are slightly different we don't
have the white but we have a green now
but overall the colors are way more
subdued this year which some people
might not love but I actually like it
and you get a textured matte back glass
glass on the back there just like on the
Pro Models and that is nice because it
resists fingerprints so let me know what
you guys think of the new colors and for
the final one that cool leak that we had
a while back about the volume buttons
being a single capacitive switch well
that did not happen and that was kind of
talked about for a while and along with
that of course I'll have a few more to
this last one the ultra did not come out
either which we were looking forward to
it's still called the pro Max and I
think we kind of know why those things
didn't happen and I think that's because
apple is saving this for the iPhone 16
Pro or 16 Ultra a lot of these leaks we
covered are most likely coming out next
year showing us that that is going to be
a huge upgrade compared to what we got
this year but you let me know your
thoughts on the iPhone 15 and 15 Pro and
the max model was this a good upgrade or
not in your opinion click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those great videos right over there this
has been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
foreign